that is terrifying oh my God this is
wild this is so sick
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am joined once again by
the one and only Tara Erickson one and
only we're gonna win Tara what are we
watching today
called missing missing
top-notch comedy today I tried you have
seen the first installment searching
years ago you don't really remember I
don't remember any of it except that he
was very good I have not seen the movie
searching well um opposite sides of the
grass yeah that's how the phrase goes I
was like well let's watch this one it's
currently number one on Netflix I
haven't even seen the trailer for this
have you no I was like what is that like
with repulsive yes I did oh trailers
seriously I don't know what this is he
was like missing I was like who
where are they why and who is it is it a
friend a family member do we like them
or not like them I would love to know
let's find out who's missing in this I
think we're in the right energy mindset
for it so ladies and gentlemen leave
that like and just for Tara's beautiful
vocals
[Music]
with your own copy of missing available
for super sexy rejects thank you all who
have joined our patreon page for all
these movie reactions alone your hair
fixing sound effects are happening right
into the microphone that was my bad you
say you're lying again I don't do
retakes here if bear gets in here person
next to me look bad I'm not doing a
retake okay if it just makes me solely
look bad retakes all day
then I look bad and you know I don't
mind it all right guys let's ruin this
movie for all of you
what's that
James
[Music]
are you okay
uh what it's a story of grief as well
oh sad
oh shoot you trying to delete them
okay keep it happy
but you two are gonna get through this
I'm here for you someday she'll
understand that's sad
man
development this morning as a green
Toyota cam wait is this like a found
footage movie or is it a splice I don't
know I'll find out why am I asking
questions shut up
[Laughter]
they're watching Netflix
[Music]
this is a very fascinating POV Siri
please
time listen I am running late and I need
you to write a couple of things down no
alcohol do not open the door for
strangers and keep your location
I left a key with Heather just call her
again so you pick Heather of all people
you do not understand the sacrifices I
made to get you mommy
you were telling me that
um okay
oh what's she what's she doing what's
she doing apple juice who spends that
much money on Apple Juice I love your
mom I know I planned this for just me
and her but it's for a very special
reason ah
oh yeah
I need you to pick us up on Monday at
LAX can you do that Monday is terrible
that's when you say no Mom that's the
real horror movie right that's true
nothing intense has happened and I'm
getting so much anxiety
it's from all those windows open on her
desk it really doesn't feel that way
this is like over stimulation of apps
everywhere would you be able to relent
wait you're gone but you can't just try
to enjoy
oh
oh so it's Father's Day
say it
oh cruel cold you're cold-hearted girl
dang okay that's a party right there in
the trunk trunk party where's the apple
juice exactly it's missing
the apple juice is What's missing
be right there
she's here hey Junie damn what a
fascinating style you know I could stay
and hang if you're bored oh no it's okay
I'm just looking forward to a quiet
night
is this what searching style is like
this is soap creative don't remember
because I like how it's still very
cinematic this is amazing like editing
yeah like what
[Music]
yeah
wow holy crap
how do you put in the words this style
it's just all from I mean brand new is
the words brand new style Greg it's just
like one of a kind screen screen found
screen footage yeah
oh cut her off right at the side there
dang
oh is it the model who goes missing
God we thought it was her the entire
time
oh snap
in Colombia that is not good oh man then
junebug's gonna become an action hero
yep kill the down two parents strong
woman arises
hi this is Grace Allen please leave a
message where are you guys I've been
standing here forever let me know when
you get this what if this is just one
giant lesson the mom's trying to teach
her cruel
[Music]
um
what do you mean look for the Popsicles
exactly
wait what
oh
[Music]
I don't know
oh my God that is so scary
dog they're gonna say no it'll work
wow this is nerve-wracking you gotta
call Heather and be like Heather you got
lawyer money we got to go to Columbia
that's what you got to do girl she just
won that lawsuit and don't forget to buy
apple juice yeah I'll make some more
calls somebody's got to be open 24 7. so
I'll just fill out this form and don't
worry I'm gonna come by first thing
tomorrow morning when the embassy opens
okay maybe he proposed she said yes and
then went and took a trip like yeah
Extended Stay she threw her phone into
the ocean yes the Romantic gesture we're
here at the moment totally and you
use evidence from a concert you have
legal access to otherwise nothing we
learn will be admissible in court hold
on I think I might have something God
this is like this feels so real oh
my God despite its really wicked Style
maybe it's her name her name weird
Junebug yeah
there we go bug
oh
[Applause]
oh my God no
is this real uh yeah I got some people I
want to check in on I don't think you'll
be able to make them out Gray
oh oh can you do that in Colombia
Go Ninja
translate to English Bobo Dan this is a
clever ass screenplay gosh this is so
good Elite
wow all right all right here we go 48 an
hour you gotta call the lawyer I'm not
worth it man oh my God
just call the lawyer the loidy I
far from here
I don't understand trying to find uh
please it's my mom you make me think of
my son never take enough for an answer
Javier was the right call I can't get
into her accounts even if I wanted to
you said she's traveling with her
boyfriend so if you can't find hers
maybe I can find him yeah to recover
your
just have to verify a couple things
starting with
with birth
November 10th 1980. great
her mother's made
Chen Julia Chen and then the name of
your Elementary School
damn you've searched fast
but Elementary
they work yeah
okay uh there's no like need to approve
on his phone or anything like that huh
yeah that's weird maybe enough service
wait he was texting me the whole time
unless he turned off his location
or someone else did the footage is
already gone oh two American tourists
live on Friday so they're going to leave
and your mother says sorry because she
spilled some wine on the bed sheets and
this is like one in the afternoon okay
no start over the shovels and and
hammers oh of cemetery oh
he wants to go grave Robbie
they're so kidnapped that's not the
store that's
that's where you go to pay too much for
the drinks ah
the workers see if they saw anything
okay
oh yeah just buy some gum to see if the
bank code matches do this Javier guy is
great he's got to move up from two stars
to five immediately yeah I hope she
gives a really honest review and stuff
it gets like terrible feedback he helped
me find my mom
are you coming over I'm sorry I gotta go
into the office I had to change a client
meeting but I'll be there
what what who's it what no matching six
months to go wait wait hold up
I think Kevin was cheating cheating what
is this he clearly has a type
oh my God okay let's get to it get to it
who are these people
what the hell wait who's Greg I'm great
oh it's him he's like
this woman calls him Darren
holy
human trafficking
slash murder
one result ah is he just like
yeah
and fraud registered to whoa there are
people who really pull like this
man that is crazy
[Music]
it's just a Twist and tourney movie man
oh my God keep in mind that all of these
cases were from before his prison
sentence but right now you are illegally
accessing Mr Lynn's account so any
evidence that I received from that gets
tossed in court this is why Batman
exists
job is to find your mom and build a
prosecutable case if there's a crime I
don't know she's unpacked way more
information than you have yeah also a
Javi is still on the run thank God she
moved it down to eight bucks an hour
uh yeah she works here and you haven't
heard from her at all nope I've tried
calling dming her I've been stopped
covering her shift for the last two
weeks well wow wow she's special do you
mind calling if you hear from her what
does that mean is she special what this
movie's bananas oh my God I thought he
turned his location off not till they
got to Colombia
seeing her oh frequently visited
two what
oh that's his murder house I'm calling
about Kevin Lynn he he visited your
house like two weeks ago June 8th what
was he doing there what it's a re-entry
entry oh and did he ever mention my mom
slice her up I got the receipt wait you
got it what did he buy
just this oh God this is not good
wait what was he doing to this woman
before exactly was he just scamming them
because I don't know he went to the
prison for three years
something weird with your mom being in
there saying some stuff that you don't
want to see
oh it's his though oh but yeah you would
see he's probably gonna miss it doesn't
matter either way oh God oh God uh Kevin
here and I thought I'd just try to get
things started what's your favorite 80s
band okay
another video you seem great and I'd
love to know more about you I certainly
admire your persistence so what would
you like to know what's your favorite
80s he asked you yes there we go follow
up New Edition
okay he totally stole my answer huh I I
tried to leave a voicemail her voicemail
is full when I look at her I just I just
see her father and it's like we've we've
really been through a lot together oh
I don't think that I could forgive
myself if anything ever happens to her
you know you've seen like a really great
mom one day she'll get that
wow this shit's so hypnotic
okay here we go about her past
I have a record I really like you and I
I just didn't want I didn't want to
screw this up but if you you don't want
to keep talking I totally get it oh poor
guy I think everything's all right yeah
I do something in her past followed her
to Colombia maybe so far away though
that thing with the this movie oh it's a
Love Lock yeah
oh
oh my God oh my God
oh the live cameras Oh but can you go
back oh you can't Javi can you wait for
me
oh yeah okay let me check the archive
you can go back huh cool
there
did you see them yeah
he has a lock and he pushes her off the
bridge
proposing what is he doing what's this
red thing here we go here we go or maybe
he's gonna oh God propose
oh my God does she say yes she said yes
no I know they were at the bridge you
were right he wasn't trying to con her
oh my God no no
oh my God
that's scary no I hate it I
hate it so much
holy who are these people oh my God
this is warning from an anonymous source
we're mobilizing units across the city
as we speak oh my God so what now is
there anything I can do the best thing
you can do to help
to help we'll be in touch oh my god look
up that license plate look at something
about money but what if these people
hurt her they have no reason to either
I've already go find them off
yeah come on any white van blow it up
oh my gosh any and all my son Carlos
lost his mom in the trouble gets worse
and one day we had this big fight and he
said I didn't even wanted to talk to me
again it doesn't change a pattern slow
have you tried reaching out he knows
what I am is he still charging her for
this
this is a 48-hour event here he's a
long-term Ninja
okay
she's drinking she doesn't drink
mocktails oh mock mock tails
what
oh that's not wine in the pic well she
could drink a lot of different things is
that not her hand and she was stolen way
before I'm confused
oh my God she helped like steal her and
be her standing I don't know but that's
bunny cake hand right and then maybe he
posted like but then no why would he
send it I'm conf I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know
her and the photos yeah oh my God
because they disappeared along
she's the stand-in I was right right oh
my God that is terrifying
oh my God the live view is gonna show
the bunny cake oh my God it's bunny cake
ah it's bunny cake
holy I can't believe this has
happened
my God
why would you not think this through you
dumbass
so he's not a good guy
so he's part of the oh my God yeah these
cells are off Grace Allen was in fact
impersonated
in an alleged scheme by the suspects
behind me of Miss Allen
we now believe never left Los Angeles
yeah
oh my God that's why he was saying
you're literally perfect
seemingly swapped out
why would he put up
because I hide his to hide the fact that
she he killed that he so the kidnapping
was all just fake for the camera
take the 405 and then a totally
different woman gets out at LAX
Kevin did something to her that's when
it happened
okay he only ever stopped for three
minutes along the way
he must have had help for the Uber
driver
the one person who knows for sure what's
going on here is Mr Lynn yeah
we find him and we find Grace Allen oh
man call that guy back from Nevada
they say that the police told us some
local students that lean hired to be
part of a movie
oh my God
oh he paid them to capture them like a
moo oh my God he said it was a reality
show oh my like a lifestyle travel thing
all shot on the iPhone and stuff oh my
God your mom was already gone Miss Paige
never saw her did she get a good look at
the driver
she couldn't see his face from back seat
yo Kevin for sure
you mentioned that you don't have any
extended family right
the best of your knowledge your mom has
never gone by any of their names
no the past
all right
turns out Grace Allen is just one of the
mystery woman's aliases whose real
identity lies locked behind a
court-ordered seal
what what the is happening
tried leaving a voicemail but I'm
writing a joke it's Angel just checking
in on things with your mom
also did you find my watch
[Laughter]
zero known family members other than the
daughter that's Palace us this is crazy
it's just the internet too no no it's
not just the internet it's the police
too hey don't let them put you down
Monday Wednesday and Friday it looks
just like this but even you said
you said right
she knew about Kevin the whole time
it's not a show this is my mom obviously
you should just go
now we're gonna find out her dad's still
alive
let's move his ability to put you in the
POV is very impressive yeah you're like
with them surging
you don't want to Google this it'll
come back to haunt you
this is nordvpn
I'll delete how to hide internet
oh oh oh
download that right away girl we
need to get there because I need to know
10 hours ago my God
they're talking to each other no are you
you uh wait
along
are you home
he's gonna be like no I'm in Colombia
no maybe it's not the mob
the lawyer
they're on to it
[Music]
uh maybe he logged back in oh
there's Heather yeah holy I knew it
right when she was like I'm not coming
over right away girl you ain't a good
friend uh
Dave she is solving so much of this on
her own I have to record her
onto the watch now I need you to stay on
the phone while I'm in there in case
something happens
because someone is a parent
it doesn't mean they do not make
mistakes
I guess you wouldn't
oh that's a cool
yo this shit's wild this is what I can
do my heartbeat is 96 so is mine yeah
girl you're doing good good
goodness crazy
oh my God what what's going on why is it
a horror movie so dark and what's
happening is she fallen over behind the
desk like she's dead now
[Music]
okay erasing local discs
money and run away together
talk she dies who dies being held
against her will she's being forced into
this
oh yeah that's her necklace oh my God is
Heather dead is she in the other room is
she she's in that dark Road she's
totally dead she's in that room she's
beaten up or something something weird
oh my God yeah she half the life
where
where oh my god oh yeah oh yep wow it
this movie
did she get her killed
but I told her then yeah look Mr Lin is
the key to all of this police may have
spotted him near the border he is our
best chance in finding your mom wow dang
the dead dad is orchestrating all this
from down below six feet
so crazy
what if she's she's being watched the
whole yeah time
looks like it
cyberghost VPN yeah I mean he set up her
computer remember
is this still Heather messaging or the
freaking Mom it's I think it's the mom I
think it's the mom okay oh my God
you know
oh my God
holy junk don't shoot him you gotta
detain him
[Applause]
what what just happened
don't shoot
flee with money stolen from missing
woman
oh girl did you clear your voicemail
maybe she's been trying to oh she's
gonna check all the voicemails
oh this is going to be sad oh my God 99
girl I feel like she's a suspect though
I don't know I don't know what to
believe God me neither that's what I'm
saying maybe if you called her hey
what hey Junebug it's
you just had the password wrong right
you didn't add the ug
that was the first guest that we when we
earlier in the movie
yeah oh
oh someone been trying to hunt your mom
down
uh what's happening
the guy who lied about the
Nevada girls the Nevada guy
in the murder house
wait
what
oh my God what how what does this mean
it's the same place
oh
my God he's killed your dad and now he
she oh my God this is Jimmy from the
from the church thing there's a line to
explain I didn't mean to scare you to
tell you what's going on right now
before I call the police
holy
holy this was not your this is a fake
person this is you were stolen as a
child
and none of this is real she's not your
real mom
what our jokes came true
there are things that you need to know
like what like oh my God you're a dirty
liar and you weren't my father and you
faked a nosebleed how I don't want to
sit here anymore me neither oh my God I
want to roam girl you better get a knife
out of the kitchen and be like you can
talk to me through the freaking window
you deserve to know what happened we all
do yeah come on get to it
oh my God you opened the door he could
be crazy
who's literally in Zach who's crazy
her real name is
we're always fighting
I've been searching for you ever since
so you scheme to get rid of her
like what
she lied to a judge to have me put in
prison so that she could have you to
herself
she lied to me oh and then him and Kevin
okay
we're in eastern prison
in Texas
why did they scheme together to get rid
of mom then she scared him in prison
yeah oh my God
driver you know where Mom is you dirty
liar
we need to hit a punching bag oh my god
oh
where is Irish
oh you got a fake like you don't know
oh my God fake like you don't know you
get
it
[Music]
oh my God sounds like she hid you away
for good reason
what's that
James
it's just the altitude
that is fine Daddy's just been doing a
lot of cocaine no big deal
my own daughter now she said I saw you
go out back
uh he's gonna like me
um
it is frustrating trying to reason with
you when you won't acknowledge Baseline
facts
less than a year then how do you explain
what I found in the hallway closet so
you need to cut the and tell me
what you did with it holy junk I swear
to God I will find you and you will die
in a pool of your own blood before you
take it from me do you hear me
oh my God I'm surprised she was able to
hide this information for so long yeah
like how did she say hidden for 12 years
from this guy
oh I can
I'm not law and oh she helped hide like
helped her stay hidden even from June
like June was never able to find this
information
safe at home okay
[Music]
oh that's why we saw in the beginning
she deleted everything okay
got it I can't imagine what you must be
going through we really hate to see you
go I really had no idea oh that was her
okay
clever
clever movie
lie
holy you're one thing and then we'll
leave
wow prison reform did nothing
she is in there
oh dang girl you almost out of there
you have a tool to use yeah you better
knock him in the head so hard that he
does not come back up
[Music]
yes yes yes hit him again oh my God
oh
no time for sorry get in the car
oh my God move I can't I really can't
get in the freaking car he killed
Heather he's crazy he thinks he's
punishing me for what I did to him I'm
gonna tell you everything
I want you to take
the holy
oh my God what is he in
um
felt like a hole that very hurt welcome
to the cemetery I talked about earlier
oh my God hello hello hello can anyone
hear me okay where's your phone it's at
the house if only I I could just just
oh call your computer call your phone do
you remember the address to this place
oh everything needs to be paired with a
phone oh God oh God wait what unless
Harvey yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I found my mom I need your help okay I
need you to go to the first picture on
my Instagram
I see great on the house behind us there
are no
five four one okay call the police and
tell them we are at four
I don't know
oh javi's gotta have filled in the blank
now I need you to come with me right now
James back off leave her alone one more
word from you and you are dead
ask again
oh my god oh I don't believe it holy
oh my God
[Music]
oh my God take that glass
oh my God shove it in his throat oh my
God kill him oh my God please come on
come on come on you can do a tune kill
him
um that's okay
I'm just making this Carter
[Music]
yes
please
come on June finish the job
the gun's in there I'm dying
anyone and anyone can hear me
oh he fell over he died
oh this is such if she died
she's gonna die this is such I
promise if we could
I'll start checking my boys videos
hey Siri
[Music]
call 9-1-1 yes what what
this is awesome God this is wild
oh my goodness
oh just a movie oh this is the dramatic
reenactment they made a Netflix movie
yeah
foreign
[Music]
listen I just wanted to remind you that
your bus leaves at 8 35 in the morning
so you might want to set multiple alarms
yep
oh guess what I got a new boyfriend Javi
unfriended me on Facebook
oh at the beginning of the movie she
said the sacrifices I've made for you oh
yeah
it just sounded like typical pear and
stuff but no no love you
there you go girl just just hit the like
button that's what I was gonna say nice
call back hit that like button Bobo
yes that's great
hahaha
she'll never forget
[Music]
oh my God that made me like tear up at
the end
yeah a little American Nick Johnson all
right man
my God that was crazy that was that was
crazy
insane
I did not really want to watch this
movie before it's terrible attest I was
not leaning towards it and we decided it
wasn't and that turned into one of the
most memorable experiences
I like all
God the twist and turns it did not stop
it didn't stop
this was insane
it was like an anxiety attack I mean
every five minutes it it kept it kept
dangling in this this like
um I don't know what the terminology is
what is the term I'm looking for a piece
of like string cheese in front of you to
go and have we crossed into the realm of
unbelievability yet is this too much for
you like the entire time but it just
kept reeling you back in and explaining
it away and you're like yeah yeah this
is nuts but I like it this is wild
wild Wackadoo wild it was only
all that I was like isn't there a window
there has to be a window in that room
and also knock down that freaking door
to get your mom out right like kick it
down but I'm okay with that that's fine
everything else before holy junk I mean
just with them showing you the lock like
in the beginning we're like me locked
her up in a basement it was like I'm
totally on board did he Gilder and like
all that stuff and holy holy junk just
and then but they have they have you
going though like when at first you're
like oh this Kevin guy is awful yeah
he's bad and then they you go through
the history and you're like ah maybe he
actually is all right yeah actually oh
we never buy it like this movie just
knew how to play it every time there was
a Twist that happened there would be
another twist that happened another one
where you it's a really good mystery
thriller that is really that is insane I
wonder if this is preferred over the
predecessor
um I mean I'm gonna tell you right now
now I will never forget this movie right
now I don't remember a lot about the a
little bit but not a lot that is just an
insane story and I I loved it I love it
okay but the one thing that was not
explained is how Kevin died right didn't
he reach I know but but we were like
come on man he was like that and then
I'm like it's yeah I would have I kind
of want to know but I'm like it doesn't
really matter like honestly this was a
wackadoo wild ride but like what did he
do why did they shoot him yeah maybe he
reached for something I don't know it's
the stock I think this style is so smart
because it is so much of just like going
through like these screens and stuff
because it
the the problem that I have with most
like found is it's not exactly found
footage but it is that I would if
there's a category to put it in I would
say found footage is there is there like
a terminology that I don't know that you
guys can explain to me because if it was
just pure found footage like someone who
just doesn't stop recording then what we
get even it would be actually even
harder to believe but to do this kind of
like hyper style editing whether it's
like a bunch of screen monitoring screen
recording and with like actually some
cinematic music inter spliced into here
with some wild editing
actually makes this quality feel more
believable because I'm never getting
pulled out going why is this still
recording that's ridiculous you know
because that's the problem with most of
these found footage things is like why
would they still be recording but to be
doing like this almost surveillance type
of quality I thought was excellent uh
yeah yeah because it keeps you in real
time in in her searching leaving notes
yeah calling the other people we're in
real time with them while also going
through found footage also the the
happenstance with the security cameras
is also was dope yeah I think it was fun
it's so fun because it starts off where
or is this going to be just some like
really
sad drama Thriller yeah
which it just starts going Congo I had I
was not prepared first oh my God this is
just gonna escalatingly get weird when
we found out it was bad bunny what was
her name bunny girl yeah oh my freaking
like what it's so well thought out so
well thought out like you got to think
about so much when you're crafting one
of these things together they thought it
through like timelessly like I'm so
fascinated with how the execution went
down yeah I'm wondering I had a
storyboard for every shot first to be
like because no one in the editing room
is going to be like what a fine if we're
seeing a computer screen but it's like
I wonder if they hadn't ever all of it
storyboarded out so that you would see
that the frame included in her shot of
face a video of her plus her Windows
plus her face time with the thing back
here right so it's like you have that's
just it's nuts well not just not just
with the way it's shot and edited how
much you got to think that out but the
writing oh yeah I don't even want to
know I mean that's why two people wrote
it and directed it because it's so much
where do you start with this yeah where
do you even begin and you're like well I
have this idea for this person missing
but we got to come up with kind of a
mystery plot around it like how do you
flush the stick out where where was the
nebulous for how how this all came to be
for it's 45 episodes of Unsolved Mystery
yeah
people do it I mean I I've seen a lot of
those like True Crime doc series and and
people go through like extreme lands
like there's a crazy that goes down
yeah things that sound like so absurd
but really happen in real life uh so uh
this doesn't this didn't cross too far
if it was if it was like the dad was
actually presumed dead and he was still
alive this whole time that right then
I'd be like okay too much but but then
but they fed it to us with the nosebleed
yeah yeah that's how that you picked up
on the drug habit right like when you
when you went back because yeah because
at the beginning you're thinking brain
aneurysm yeah like oh the moment
[Music]
it is so well crafted I'm just so
impressed by how how much they thought
this story through from beginning to end
and and and like for every twist
for every every curveball they throw you
right down to the woman uh where you're
like hired actors then they explain it
and you're like
oh yeah
first payment but not the second one
everything is thought out yeah for every
twist there was a turn every detail is
thought out and storm rate do you
remember her from The Last of Us episode
uh when and the one in the mall I yeah
that was her yeah yeah at the beginning
okay if you're on YouTube there's this
whole thing about on our patreon intro
where I was trying to tell you that's
who it was and then we ended up just
talking about Stormy Daniels yeah
all different things he interrupted me
yeah you're like oh is it this person
and then I never told you who it was
that's who it was she's phenomenal in
this room great phenomena held this
movie Down dang girl yeah amazing
and they even made the relationship uh
really believable with how it forms with
the Javi oh yeah I I I'm like oh of
course he has a sentiment because he
lost his not lost his son but didn't
have contact and she's the same age so
he would of course be that guy who's
willing to help out a very young girl
try to find her mom yeah like of course
he would be like you don't even have to
pay me my eight dollars and also
probably still answer her calls yeah
because they formed and it was not
unbelievable that they had only talked
twice and that you know he he even said
I hope your money hasn't gone to waste
so I'm wondering she obviously was able
to pay him something which is why he was
able to follow up go to the Love Lock
thing then after that it just became a
genuine relationship uh especially when
she found the footage right yeah because
then the footage made it oh Javi now
sees mom was kidnapped because she
probably was like look look here they
were the love luck white van yeah and
then he's like oh this is not made up
he's in it now and he I mean of course
like how would you not want to see it
through and or be there for her when she
calls right like
after I've just kind of I've started I'm
sorry so mindful about what we just
witnessed that was such a crazy ride so
good it was a roller coaster in somehow
the the writers thought if we added in
for her for him to just go what happened
to your father we didn't read into that
that wasn't even Exposition in my brain
at all for Javi to go what happened to
your father
we're all kind of thinking that a little
bit but not really then and then they
also bring up somehow in that
conversation it's like two minutes where
they get a heart to heart so now we
actually have formed a relationship with
Javi when for me as a writer I'd be like
we're running out of time it's not going
to seem realistic for Javi and her to
talk about his son who's gone and he
never talked to a son before how do we
add that in I believed it that it came
out genuinely I didn't feel that that
plot line was forced and that's what
comes through that's a nice callback at
the end right because she says you
should talk to your son yeah the way
they tether every there's like there's
so many different kinds of callbacks
right down to the whole Siri Motif at
the this is a great advertisement for
Apple uh yeah right down to the to the
Siri Motif at the very end Nicole into
it like they get you really even if
you're not like tech savvy they get I
feel like it gets you really because
they were doing things like I didn't
know you could do that but it gets you
acquainted with essentially the rules of
the tech so well that you can buy into a
lot of things if there's like a nitpick
that maybe I would have in this movie
and it's but I was so pulled in that I
wasn't even really thinking about it was
just how fast she can like search for
stuff yes like things just go chips
even when they're like fake calling to
pretending to be Kevin like there's no
way you look like I've tried cheating on
before right like I'm doing a quiz
at a bar you can't do that you can't
move that fast it's not that fast yeah
what is this 7g yeah it's insane
ridiculous but other than that you're so
wrapped into the immediacy of the of the
anxiety of the situation at all times
that you're not even thinking about some
of these things that are a little bit
too far-fetched because there's no
mistake in it the problem that happens
with like found footage is that they try
to make a lot of times I try to make it
so real that you get pulled out when
something's obviously not real this
movie he knows to ride the line between
we're definitely doing cinema right now
like this is a movie yeah that is in the
guise of a found footage you know what I
mean yeah and I think they did such an
excellent job at that uh on all fronts
and they managed to have like a great
character narrative uh throughout the
dad being like totally unhinged at the
end and going full bomb villain that
might have been a little
I I felt like there was like zero Nuance
to that by the end like he was just so
like villainous by the end yeah like why
is he gonna like tie up his daughter and
make it he's already now bad to her at
that point when he was tying her up I'm
like how are you gonna
you can't explain this yourself like
you're you're now you've locked her in
her room with her mom and you shot her
mom so like where do we go from here
with him like what's his thought process
which I didn't I didn't understand that
but also remember how they were like
money went somewhere so the money went
to Kevin
right and then Kevin and maybe the dad
they just shared it so I guess the plan
was to steal all the money the money
come out and run away with the daughter
yeah I'm just like dad you can't come
back from that daughter's not she's not
she does not like you like this is an
ultimate this was just as massive
massive Revenge plan right to be like
you're gonna hurt as much as I did you
took my daughter away now I take your
daughter away from you maybe he wasn't
planning to kill mom he just that's why
he shot her in the what was the pro I
mean I I would feel like the LAPD would
stay with June the whole time yeah like
why are they like here a buy 13 14 year
old one in the morning and we're gonna
go now for sure so like this is the time
when the Killer goes yeah you know yeah
that I mean she she is she is 18. that's
the same time I still feel like it's
like what is this like specific time
shift that they have to stick around
like just no bad guys showing up tonight
we're gonna we're gonna take off now
little nitpicks like that but other than
that the movie is dazzlingly impressive
because because they have thought
through every single through line and
and like so many different plot holes
like this movie I I we're probably like
a couple of we're raising a couple of
questions is what we're doing not not
even sure but if it's a nitpick a lot of
it is like questions the but this movie
thought about so much that could have
been just big ass plot holes and and
leaps into suspension of disbelief like
they thought of so many different things
and and literally like every 10 minutes
whenever they presented something that
could have been too much they managed to
answer the question they managed to
explain it without a lot of exposition
like we didn't know where hair where
which side Heather was on we thought she
was messaging me like she's in on it and
then she goes to find her and the only
way that we really knew besides yes the
guy says it later but we knew because
the picture said if you talk she dies
yeah and that was our only information
that we got that Heather is like oh she
was being set up and and then skipped to
the guy kind of explaining it that yeah
she was she she wasn't in on it and now
we gotta go to the next person
yeah his great propulsive music it was a
great mystery a little fantastic acting
yeah
um and uh just just an immense amount of
emotions it was a very emotional too
yeah it's very emotional with great
character resolved by the end and a lot
of great misleads throughout
if the missing people see this who are
the two people I called their names out
at the end because I was like I should
remember their names now listen will
Merrick and John something
send me a t-shirt you know what I mean
where's the missing merchandise and now
I need some merch okay I need it in my
life uh writers and directors can make
that happen I know you got a box in your
house that you didn't give to all of the
crew
so
over here you know what it also did so
well
is in the beginning the first half
before it gets all twist and turny right
you know before it get because there's
there is there's a lot I thought you
said turdy yeah because because there's
a lot there is a lot of like very
specific visuals that take some
adjusting like especially I don't know
if this is the way the movie searching
operates but for me on my first go
around like this is kind of an
adjustment of a visual experience that I
was having at the very beginning uh it
was like a little bit over stimulating
and yeah at the same time though
as every like what was the first big
twit the Kevin guy right whenever what
his past is and things having an affair
and stuff yes before it gets there the
way they handled everything was
extremely relatable you know yeah like
the choices she was making how she was
going about the choices the interactions
that she was having they made so many
things of like this is how a lot of us
would go about in the operation of this
and thinking it through and and and even
like certain apps that were being used
and how to handle it like I was it was
so so impressed with how relatable it
was feel right down to the even the
taskrabbit of having to lower the price
reduction and everything like that right
they made so many relatable choices for
everyone to connect to
that way when it starts getting a little
bit more heightened and and and uh I
don't want to say ridiculous but just
hide it yeah you're still on board
because they've already got you so
connected to the realistic the reality
yeah they grounded it really well with
an anchor in the beginning so as you go
through you're like
you weren't thrown out at the top to go
this is unbelievable you're like no this
is believable like
yeah
um that was frantic and exciting I I
loved it I was great and it was a real
mindfulness really it really was it just
didn't stop it was like scary in all the
right ways every single way guys Bravo
what did you think about this movie
visic leave your thoughts down below
um I hope this movie gets more attention
I'm only see it's got a thousand
thousand people voted on Rotten Tomatoes
that's it come on
she deserves it and uh we'll see you
guys soon thanks for being here Maria
Maria Hammond my dear
so
she got me this uh Doctor Strange Cape
that you might have seen me wearing a
couple of videos before
and then I just opened a package that we
got from her which had this really
lovely letter and here's a photo of me
rocking this cable and I was walking
around WonderCon this year
and then there was a special present in
this box that I just took out
and she didn't say she wanted an
unboxing video so I was like all right
well let me just take a look at it then
and I wish I did an unboxing video
because she got me the eye of agamoto it
is they're gonna be right here we're
gonna put it in the background and oh my
God it is so cool it is so wickedly cool
I I legit love this so much I was so
surprised to see it
um we're gonna be doing another live
stream and I'm definitely gonna be
wearing this the entire time because
wowza look at that oh my God wait wait
wait oh I think you see the eye yeah
yeah I just there's the eye there's the
eye of agamoto right there
thank you so much Maria you know this
movie deals with someone
um in search of their mother and I've
said it several times if there's anyone
who would be like the mother at our
patreon page it would be you thank you
for constantly spoiling us and for being
such a
such a a nurturing Soul at every corner
and yeah I just love the hell out of you
so I just want to keep this simple and
keep it short of course thank you for
this awesome gift but mainly thank you
so much for being you
this is really this is really freaking
sweet and I love the hell out of you my
dear
thank you
[Music]